Das sind wirklich große pläne und ein einmaliges projekt europa will ab dem jahr 2024 das größte
erdgebundene teleskope der welt betreiben und die vorbereitungen dafür laufen auf hochtouren mit dem extremely large telescope e elt
in den chilenischen bergen stehen die chancen gut unser wissen über das universum zu
revolutionieren unter anderem soll das rt nach außerirdischem leben ausschau halten wie das gigantische teleskop genau aufgebaut wird was es
schlussendlich leisten wird und welche spannenden ergebnisse sich die forschungsteams
erträumen das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt den klicks hensel fiction herzlich willkommen ja und vielen dank für euren themenvorschlag auf whatsapp
Dass et wird das leistungsfähigste und ehrgeizigste teleskop seiner art sein das sagt der präsident der europäischen südsternwarte
des european southern
observatoriums oprah trikot auch bei der grundsteinlegung des extremely large telescope
sell r im vergangenen jahr im mai 2017 unter generaldirektor tim den zwölf
ergänzt der sprung von den gegenwärtigen
teleskopen zum lte ist etwa so groß wie der sprung von galli virus auge zu seinem teleskop
das et führt also in eine neue ära der astronomie und das in gewaltigen dimensionen der hauptspiegel des teleskops
wird fünf mal größer sein und dadurch
13 mal mehr licht anfangen können als es bei den derzeit besten teleskope möglich ist dass ist eine
garantie für sehr viele schärfere bilder im vergleich zum weltraumteleskop hubble
wird es wohl 16 mal kleinere details erkennbar machen und es geht weiter allein sein gewaltiger drehbarer kuppel aufbau mit einem durchmesser von
85 metern ist von der größe her vergleichbar mit der fläche eines fußballfeldes das lte soll vor allem
exoplaneten unter die lupe nehmen denn dort könnte es bislang unentdecktes leben geben wir berichten ja immer wieder davon die
planetenforschung weltweit über bietet sich derzeit darin den ersten bewohnbaren exo planeten aufzuspüren aber auch
supermassereiche schwarze löcher und die rätsel um die verteilung der dunklen materie und der dunklen energie
könnten mit dem gigantischen
teleskop gelöst werden ein besonderes augenmerk soll auch auf der frühgeschichte und der zukunft des universums liegen und das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen
von den etwa 2005
astrophysikern und astrophysikerin in deutschland werden wohl zwei drittel mit den daten des
lte arbeiten im vergangenen jahr im mai 2017 wurde in mainz der sekundär spiegel aus glaskeramik
gegossen das war der erste meilenstein in dem wirklich aufwändigen herstellungsprozesses
lte etwa ein jahr hat sein abkühlung prozess gedauert und jetzt wird er noch in frankreich geschliffen und poliert sein durchmesser beträgt
wahnsinnige vier meter und sein gewicht
3,5 tonnen somit ist er der größte sekundär spiegel eines teleskops weltweit und zudem der grösste
konvexe spiegel der menschheit er wird kopfüber
dem hauptspiegel aufgehängt seine aufgabe wird darin bestehen dass von vom riesigen hauptspiegel eingefangene licht über weitere spiegel hin zu den messinstrumenten
zu leiten aber auch der hauptspiegel ist nicht ohne denn um diese leistungsfähigkeit zu erreichen sind rekordleistung nötig in besteht aus knapp
800 einzelnen 66 spiegeln die beweglich sind und sich die spiegel form so bei jeder temperatur und der neigung des teleskops
optimal anpassen kann konkret wird das egt auf einem abgelegenen
berggipfel in chiles atacama wüste zu hause sein da war ich auch schon mal da ist es sehr hoch und sehr trocken
der amazonas berg ist und 3000 meter hoch und vor zwei jahren wurde seine spitze gesprengt um eine plattform für das mega teleskop
errichten zu können hier in der atacama-wüste betreibt die eso teleskop an drei standorten unter anderem auch das very large telescope vlt
das besteht aus vier teleskopen die sich miteinander kombinieren lassen so könnte eine ein euro münze aus einer entfernung von 5000
kilometern erkannt werden und die bedingungen in dieser region sind für astronomische studium besonders geeignet denn
größere städte mit störenden lichtquellen die sind weit entfernt zudem ist die luft klar und trocken
und die sogenannte humboldt strömung sorgt dafür dass die region meist komplett wolkenfrei ist optimale bedingungen also für
wissenschaftliche
sternenbeobachtung auch wenn es ein wenig kurios klingt von dieser abgelegenen ecke der erde
lebenszeichen im weltall zu finden das erp projekt läuft seit 2012 ende 2014 wurde sein bau genehmigt zehn jahre später
also
2024 wird das mega teleskop dann wohl erstmalig an den start gehen dahinter steckt wie gesagt die europäische die sternwarte die im oktober
1962 durch deutschland belgien frankreich schweden und den niederlanden gegründet wurde mittlerweile gehört sie mit zu den erfolgreichsten
forschungseinrichtungen europas derzeit hat sie 15 mitgliedsstaaten die finanziell technisch und wissenschaftlich zum
projekt beitragen deutschland ist das größte aller mitglieder und steuert
230 millionen euro von den baukosten dazu insgesamt sieht es nach kosten von 1,1 milliarden euro aus
und wir haben hier auch großes vor klicks um
werbefrei zu machen nämlich nämlich immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor einem monatlichen video ab werdet also
mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken oder auf den linken der video beschreibung für einen kleinen beitrag
bekommt den dazu noch einige extras und wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann
hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt ihr den link zum aktuellen video vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken
und darunter geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken natürlich hast du ihn bedrohen die erde jederzeit und das ist wirklich der fall also bis dann
bleibt dran